BRANDON ROYAL: Hi, I'm Brandon
Royal, solution manager
and technical strategist for
CI/CD and Anthos Solutions
here at Google Cloud.
I'm joined by my colleague,
Ben Good, solution architect
and DevOps expert,
also at Google Cloud.
During today's
session, we'll discuss
some of the common
challenges that customers
see when it comes to modernizing
their CI/CD, especially around
hybrid cloud deployments
of that infrastructure.
We'll review some of
the core principles
that we think about when
architecting and modernizing
CI/CD solutions with
enterprise customers.
And finally, we'll
discuss how Anthos
can be leveraged
within your environment
to build more robust, consistent
pipelines across not only
on-prem as well as hybrid
cloud environments;
enable those pipelines
for not only application
configuration but also
policies and configuration;
and ultimately help
your application teams
to deploy code faster.
Now, CI/CD is not a new concept.
It's been around for
at least a decade,
and a lot of the
tools and practices
really haven't
changed that much.
What has changed
quite significantly
is the infrastructure
surrounding CI/CD.
So specifically, we've
moved from a more imperative
infrastructure, where
we're describing
all the changes that we need
to do within our pipelines
to more of a declarative
infrastructure,
not only for our applications
but also our underlying
infrastructure and
security policies.
Now, speaking of
security, security
often has a very
different operating model
from developers and operations.
And we see that as
a point of friction
with a lot of our customers.
And then we also are seeing
very inconsistent tools
between on-premises deployments
of CI/CD and cloud deployments.
Many of our customers
describe that they
have one very
different set of tools
for managing and deploying
the test-built automation
for their Cloud-based
applications
and a very different
one for on-premises.
And we all know there's
manual processes that
are involved in especially
configuration changes
across environments.
And we find that's
a huge issue when
creating those
inconsistencies, especially
between multiple
cloud environments.
Now, DevOps Research and
Assessment, the organization
that brings you the
state of DevOps support,
published some really
interesting findings
when it comes to
DevOps performance.
This report has tons
and tons of details,
but some of the
most important parts
are DevOps'
performance is directly
correlated with
organizational performance.
So improving the performance of
your CI/CD pipelines, the pace
at which you're
deploying your code,
time in which it takes you
to recover from any service
degradation is
directly correlated
to your organization's
performance.
Also, the selection
of cloud-based tools
have a very meaningful
impact in your ability
to be a high performer within
those key DevOps metrics.
And the last in this
course isn't going
to be surprising to anyone.
Organizations that
are using more slow
change management
approval processes
using standard ticketing-based
methods often don't perform
as well as those that are using
more GitOps-based methods.
And that's what we're going to
talk a little bit about today.
Now, when we think
about modernizing CI/CD,
we think about these
five principles.
First, we look at security.
So security is not
only in terms of how
we create a secure
pipeline, but also
how do we create a very
clear separation of duties
between developers,
operators, and security.
And we'll talk
specifically about what
those responsibilities are.
We want to make sure that
we're securing the pipeline
through vulnerability
management and attestation
so we're able to
cryptographically sign
our images as they go from
build to test to deployment.
And we want to manage the entire
process using robust access
control.
Now, we talked a
lot about imperative
versus declarative
infrastructure.
We want to manage all
of our configuration,
from application configuration
down to infrastructure
configuration, as code.
That allows us to have a single
auditable source of truth
for all of our
applications and also
gives us a clean
Git-based interface
in which we can manage
all those configurations.
We want to talk about
automation, of course.
That's what's
CI/CD is all about.
But we not only want to look at
automating our code deployment
process, but also our
security policy process.
So the way in which we are
managing those security
configurations across
multicluster environments
is critical to automate as well.
And we want to leverage
containers wherever possible,
not only for the
applications-- because that's
what's going to
provide that isolated,
extensible environment--
but also for our actual
build infrastructure itself.
Google has a
significant commitment
to Kubernetes'
open-source ecosystem.
And we want to make
sure that we're
providing open standards-based
interfaces for all
of our CI/CD
infrastructure, allowing
you to leverage the existing
investments that you
have in place today.
So what does that mean?
Ultimately, that
process of modernizing
your CI/CD practices
with Anthos is
going to help your developers
reduce burden and focus
on value-add tasks,
developing code and providing
to your customers.
It will help you to
establish better governance
across your entire
CI/CD process and allow
you to share those best
practices between development
teams so one development
team can benefit
from the innovation of another.
And finally, we
want to provide--
and this solution ultimately
will help to provide--
flexibility to deploy those
same configurations across cloud
environments as well as
on-prem environments.
So when we think about CI/CD,
it's more than just the CI/CD
pipelines themselves.
CI/CD pipelines are absolutely
important in our testing
process and our
deployment process.
But we also want to think
about what's below the surface.
And very similar to a
bridge structure where
below the roadway there's
all kinds of complexities
in managing the structure bridge
itself or the roadway itself,
we want to think about CI/CD
in a very similar way, where
the underlying structure
is our platform
configuration and our
management and our ability
to manage those configurations
across environments
and ultimately to orchestrate
and automate the underlying
infrastructure that
supports our applications
and our CI/CD pipelines.
The way that we do this
is we break down a problem
into components.
So we talk about this in
terms of the CI/CD component
taxonomy.
These are the major
components that anyone
needs to think
about when they're
deploying a CI/CD process.
And we want to ensure with
this methodology you're
able to leverage
existing components
that you might have
in place already,
including things like
application observability.
You might have
robust CD pipelines
that you want to continue to
use or maybe even CI pipelines.
So this solution allows you
to plug in these existing
investments and manage
them on top of Anthos
for that ultimate consistency.
When we talk about
various stakeholders
in the organization,
generally, we
talk about developers,
operators, and security.
Each one has slightly
different goals
when it comes to modernizing
their approach to CI/CD.
The operations teams
are here to standardize
how application
teams are onboarded
and how those applications
are managed over time.
The security team has a
new set of challenges.
They ultimately need
to inject and propagate
all of those application
policies and configurations
for not only one environment
but multiple environments,
potentially spread across
multiple clouds and developers.
We talked about
developers needing
to focus on developing
and providing code.
So we want to reduce the burden
for those developers wherever
possible and allow them
to provide that value as
quickly as possible.
One of the ways in which
we do that in this solution
is to provide
standard interfaces.
And these are all open
standard interfaces
that we use in order to
plug in those existing
points into the Kubernetes
ecosystem wherever possible.
The first is standard
Git-based interfaces,
and Git allows us to have
that Git-based or GitOps-based
process, in which we are
deploying all of our code
and configurations directly
through Git repositories.
The second is
container-based images.
Ultimately, we can describe
our application but also
our infrastructure using
standard OCI-based images.
And last, these are all
ultimately Kubernetes objects.
Anthos provides that
Kubernetes platform.
And using things like Anthos
Configuration Management, that
allows us to manage
those Kubernetes
manifests across
multiple environments.
So let's talk a little
bit about the workflow.
some of these aspects will seem
very familiar to those of you
who are already
deploying CI/CD workflows
within your on-prem
environments.
The first is the
developer workflow.
We want to allow our developers
to start with their application
code repository and use
a continuous integration
pipeline to build, to
test, and ultimately deploy
into a staged environment.
This pipeline will build
our container images
and will push them into
a Container Registry.
Now, next up is our operator.
Our operator in
this case is going
to start with not the
application code repository
but a different repository
specifically designed
to share code best practices.
Now, this repository
will contain
all of the shared standards
for various applications
that might be deployed
within the enterprise.
And that operator can
use inheritance models
that we'll talk
about here shortly
to manage the configuration
delta between what's
deployed in the
developer's application
and what's managed in the shared
best practices repository.
The operator will trigger a
pipeline specifically designed
for rendering all of
the configurations.
So using a tool like
customize or like help,
we can actually take
multiple configurations
that might be shared
across our shared
best practices repository and
the application repository
and render them into fully
hydrated manifests in what we
call our environment repository.
And that environment repository
is our single source of truth.
That's where we can audit
all of our configurations.
As we'll see in the
demo, we can see
all of these specific
configurations,
even down to the
hashes of our images
that are deployed in
various environments.
And then last and
certainly not least,
our security, they need to use
an Anthos Configuration Manager
repository, or ACM,
repository to manage
not only their infrastructure
configuration but also
their policies, which will be
then propagated to the clusters
using Anthos
Configuration Management.
Now, as far as the application
configurations are concerned,
again we want to start with a
shared set of best practices.
So that allows us to use things
like a base configuration
for using customize,
in this case,
to describe what are the common
configurations that we might
have across our applications.
And most applications,
there's lots of similarities
that might help.
So we want to share those
best practices essentially.
The second repository, the
Application Code Repository,
that's where we're going to
patch those configurations.
So anything above and beyond
those baseline configurations,
that's where we're
going to specify those--
things like the images or any
additional port configuration
or other application-specific
configuration that might apply.
Ultimately that will render a
fully hydrated manifest that
then gets stored within
our environment repository,
giving us that single
source of truth.
So that's the
application workflow.
What about the
security workflow?
Security workflow is all
about policy management.
So we of course manage our
underlying infrastructure.
But the core responsibility
of security in this context
is managing the propagation
of various policies.
This can be anything from
Pod Security Policies
to firewall policies.
Anything that describes the
behavior to essentially provide
guardrails to application teams
is what we define as a policy.
Now, these are ultimately stored
directly as Kubernetes objects
and are handled by Anthos
Configuration Management.
So under the hood, Anthos
Configuration Management
is listening to that repository.
And it allows our
security teams,
in coordination
with our operations
teams and development teams,
to push those policies
and configurations.
ACM takes care of rest,
taking those configurations
and propagating them
across those clusters,
allowing for full code review,
continuous integration,
and full integration into
developing an ecosystem.
Now, to show us a little
bit about how that works,
I'm going to hand
it over to Ben.
BEN GOOD: Thanks, Brandon.
Let's take a look at the demo.
Let's take a look at a
couple of the workflows
that Brandon was just describing
in the CI/CD on Anthos
presentation.
So before we dig
into the exact--
into the workflows, let's take
a look at the GKE clusters
that we have deployed and
what we'll be using them for.
So what we have four
clusters that we'll be
using to run our applications.
The first is a Dev Cluster.
So in the demo, we use Skaffold
to automatically detect
the changes to the
application code
and then deploy them
into the Dev Cluster.
This will enable us to live test
our changes on the Dev Cluster
before we push them
into the repository.
From there, when they're
pushed into the main line
of the application
code repository,
a deployment is
automatically kicked off,
which deploys our changes
to the staging cluster.
Then, when we've validated our
changes on the staging cluster,
we can merge the
environment configuration
from the staging branch into
the main line branch, which
would trigger the production
deployment to our two
production clusters.
The fifth cluster
that we have out
here is used for
our shared services.
So on that cluster
we're running GitLab.
And that's where we'll be
storing our source code
and running our CI/CD pipelines.
So now let's pretend that
I'm an application developer
and I have a simple
Go application.
If we take a look at that,
we see that it simply
outputs hello world.
And my task is to update reading
this output from hello world
to something else.
So as a good developer,
what we'll do
is we'll start by
creating a new branch.
We'll call it new greeting.
And before I start
making changes here,
I want to get Skaffold started.
So it's connected up to
our development cluster.
Let's first make sure that
we're in the right context here.
So Skaffold is going to
watch our source code.
And as it changes,
it's automatically
going to build new
versions of the container,
push them into
artifact registry,
and then run deployments on
those new container images
out to our development clusters,
so that way we can test.
So we can see here that
Skaffold is up and running.
And if we preview, we can
see hello world, this output.
So now we're ready to get
started with our changes.
So we'll go to our editor here.
So we're going to
say, hello Google.
So that'll be our new greeting.
So we can see, as I've
changed back to Cloud Shell,
that Skaffold has
detected that change
and is already starting
to rebuild the image.
Now the image has been deployed.
So if we refresh in our browser,
there is our new greeting.
And that looks good.
So we're ready to push our
changes into our source control
system and kick off
the CI/CD pipelines.
Let's stop Skaffold here.
And we'll commit our changes.
And we'll push them out.
So now, if we go
over into GitLab
and we log in as
the developer here--
me, in this case--
we can see that I just
pushed a new branch.
So let's go out and
create a merge request.
So at this point,
what's happening is
we're running a CI
pipeline on our branch.
And we are running tests.
We're going to
hydrate the manifest.
And we're going to validate
the manifest as well.
So we're running a
subset of the stages
that we'll run later
on, so everything
except for the deployment
part of the pipeline.
So this is giving
us the opportunity
to validate any manifest
changes that we might have made
in the application code
repository, as well
as any application changes.
And we'll just have GitLab
merge when it succeeds.
We can see through the comments
here that everything is merged.
If we look at our
CI/CD pipelines,
we're now running
another pipeline.
So in this one, we're
running tests again.
We're going to
build our new image.
And we're going to hydrate
and validate configs.
And then we're going
to push those configs
into our environment repository.
So while we wait
for this to run,
let's take a quick
look at our repository
and what we have in here.
So in here we have our
source code, so our main.go
with our greeting.
We have our Dockerfile.
And then we have some
Kubernetes manifests.
So these manifests are the
changes that we want to make.
So in this case, we're
setting the environment
to dev for each environment.
And if we look at
staging or production,
we can see that we're also
setting the environment
to prod.
So these changes are
getting merged together
with the common
shared best practices
that are stored in this
shared customized basis.
So here's our shared basis.
And this is a fuller manifest,
so those environment settings
are getting merged into this.
And what the CI pipeline,
the CI/CD pipeline, is doing
is it is going to
commit those manifests,
push those manifests into
the stadium branch here.
So it's still running
at this point.
So our pipeline is now finished.
So if we go and look at
our environment repository
in our staging
branch, we can see
that we just pushed new configs,
both staging and production
YAMLs.
We hydrate them all
at the same time
so they're consistent and see
they are all fully hydrated
manifest.
What that push did is that
push triggered a pipeline
to deploy those manifests to
our staging Kubernetes cluster.
And that's now done.
So if we switch
back to Cloud Shell,
now we can see what we have
running in our namespace.
And our application
is now running,
and it's been running
for 24 seconds.
So we have deployed our
changes to our staging cluster.
Now we'll quickly promote those
changes from the staging branch
into the main line branch.
And that will trigger the
production deployment.
So we'll go in here.
We'll make a new merge request.
We'll merge those.
If we take a quick peek
at the changes here,
we can see that all we
really changed was the hash.
But that merge request has
now triggered the deployment
to production.
So we'll switch to our
prod central context.
And we can see that our
new pods have been running
for 14 seconds, so our
deployment to our production
clusters succeeded.
Now for the next workflow.
As the developer, I've been
talking with the Hipster Shop
front end team.
They also have their application
running on our cluster,
and they would like
to be able to connect
to our Go application that
we've been working with.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to switch over to the
Anthos Config Management
repository.
You can see here we have all of
our namespaces and our cluster
registries and that
kind of stuff in there.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to make a quick
change to our network policy
to allow Hipster Shop front
end to connect to our Go app.
So first, before we
get started here,
let's take a quick look at
our current network policies.
So we can see that
right here we have
just a default deny
for anything that's
not within our namespace.
Now, what we're
going to do is we're
going to enable that for
the Hipster Shop front end.
So let's start again
by creating a branch.
And then we'll jump
back over to our editor.
And then here's
our network policy
that is sitting inside of our
namespaces and our managed
applications, so our Go app.
So this policy is going to allow
traffic from the Hipster front
end to connect to
our Go application.
We'll say that.
And then let's push our change.
So our change has been pushed.
So if we jump back over to the
GitLab UI here, what we'll see
is we just pushed a new branch.
So since I pushed that
branch as the developer,
I'm going to create
a merge request.
So we're going to allow traffic
from the hipster front end.
So we'll submit
that merge request.
Now, our policy has been set
up such that, as a developer,
I'm not allowed to merge
requests into the mainline.
So we're going to have to switch
over to our network admin.
So now I'm going to be
our network administrator.
And we'll review
those policy changes
so that way we can
now merge that request
and then allow that traffic.
And while we're
doing that, you can
see that we've kicked off
another CI pipeline where
we're verifying the
changes that we're
making to our configuration.
So we're running CI on
our Anthos configurations.
We'll switch over.
And we have a
merge request here.
So now I'm in as the
network administrator.
And we see the
merge request here
from me wanting to allow traffic
from the Hipster front end
into our Go application.
So while we were doing that,
all of our tests passed.
So let's quickly
view our changes.
So there's our
changes that we made.
They look good.
So let's merge them.
And now we're going
to run CI on them
again, just to make sure
everything is still good.
And when CI has
finished, we'll be
able to go out to our cluster.
And we'll see that this
change has been applied.
And we'll check it on both the
production stage and cluster.
CI is finished.
So now if we jump back
out to Cloud Shell
and we look at our
network policies again,
now we see that we're
allowing traffic
from application Hipster front
end into our Go app namespace.
So that process--
as a developer,
I needed to make a
network policy change.
I made the change in the
Anthos configuration management
repository.
And then that change was
reviewed and approved
by a network administrator.
As we saw in the demo, we
had several applications
deployed across a number of
clusters, both preproduction
and production.
Each application ran
in their own namespace
or their own little
playground, so that way
they ran in an
isolated environment.
In order to allow applications
to communicate with each other,
we had to involve the
operations and security team.
So that way we could
update the network policies
for those namespaces.
And those policies
and configurations
were being managed
using ACM, automatically
being deployed and reconciled
across all the clusters.
Now, as a developer,
they can focus
on using a GitOps workflow.
So developers can build new
features in feature branches.
And using tools like
Skaffold, those changes
can be automatically deployed
to a development cluster
so they can be live tested.
When those changes are finished,
a merge request is created.
And when they're merged
into the main line,
the staging deployment
is automatically
triggered by the push
of hydrated manifests
into the staging branch of
the environment repository.
After those changes have
been validated on the staging
cluster, the operations
team or the developer,
depending on your workflow,
can create a merge request
to promote the configurations
from the staging branch
to the main line branch.
And when those changes are
merged into the main line,
the deployment to production
is automatically triggered.
So using the principles
that we described,
you are now able to build
upon a secure platform
where you're creating
and deploying
your policy using Anthos
Configuration Manager.
You're storing that
configuration as code.
So you automatically
get the tracking
and traceability
provided by Git.
And as you saw in the demo,
everything is highly automated,
from the deployment
of application changes
all the way through the
configuration changes
that are tested and
deployed using ACM.
We're also using containers.
So we're leveraging the
immutable nature of containers
to increase the reproducibility
of our deployments
in our infrastructure.
And we're leveraging
Anthos and Kubernetes
as an open source,
standards-based infrastructure
that you can then extend your
infrastructure even further.
Brandon, I would like to
thank you for your time today.